Welcome to the deep dive.
This is where we take a whole
stack of sources, research
sometimes conflicting ideas, and
really try to boil them down to
what you need to know to make
sense of things.
That's the goal, and today we're
tackling something pretty
fundamental, I think, about how
many of us view America.
Yeah, definitely.
We have this image, right?
The US as this, you know,
vibrant tapestry, maybe a
melting pot or a beautiful
mosaic, This place where all
these different cultures just
sort of mingle freely, making
everything richer.
It's a powerful image, very
comforting.
But what if it's?
Well, what if it's not the full
picture?
What if that idea, that
comfortable image, is actually
hiding something?
Maybe a bit more unsettling.
Exactly what if that whole
notion of harmonious pluralism,
this kind of effortless mixing,
is just the surface, and
underneath there's actually a
much more active, sometimes
pretty forceful process going
on?
OK, so that's where we're headed
today.
Yeah, our deep dive today is
going to unpack a really
provocative idea from our
sources, pluralism and the
Dremel.
Pluralism and the Dremel.
OK.
And it's not just a catchy
phrase.
It's meant as a pretty precise
metaphor.
It suggests that what America
calls pluralism is often this
continuous, sometimes subtle,
but sometimes, you know, kind of
brutal process of, well, forced
assimilation.
Right.
So forced assimilation, hiding
behind the idea of pluralism.
Let's really get into that
because the implications are
huge.
You really are.
So our mission here is to really
grapple with this Dremel
metaphor.
What does it actually mean?
How does it change how we think
about pluralism and maybe even
how we understand something like
racism in the US?
Absolutely.
We'll look at historical
examples, see how it plays out
today, and maybe challenge some
some deeply held assumptions you
might have about culture,
identity, power, all of that.
OK, so listeners, be prepared.
This might shift your
perspective a bit.
It might.
We're hoping to offer some
perhaps surprising, maybe even
uncomfortable insights into how
all this stuff, culture,
identity, power really interacts
here, looking beyond that
idealized picture.
All right, let's dive in.
The core argument, as our source
puts it, is American pluralism
as hegemony plus flavor.
Hegemony plus flavor, yeah, and
right away that challenge is the
usual.
More romantic view doesn't.
It it does so the base culture,
the hegemon is defined as well,
hamburgers and apple pie.
Right.
And obviously that's not just
about food.
It represents the dominant, sort
of unchanging core of American
identity values, norms, the
default setting if you like.
The default setting OK and then
pluralism comes in as the
flavor.
Exactly.
Pluralism in this model allows
for these sort of superficial
additions, cosmetic changes
almost.
The source says you can add hot
sauce, paprika, cardamom,
turmeric.
Or swap in a Turkey Patty if
your religion forbids beef.
OK, I see.
So these are the bits of
diversity that are OK, even
celebrated sometimes.
Yeah, they're tolerated, even
welcomed as sort of vibrant
additions like seasoning you
sprinkle on top of the main
dish.
But, and this sounds like the
crucial part, there's a
boundary, an unspoken line.
A very important one.
The source stresses that even
with these added flavors, the
key thing is that the dish is
still recognizably American.
It's still fundamentally that
hamburger and apple pie.
So anything that tries to go
beyond just adding flavor, like
trying to make a totally
different dish or live by
different rules.
That's precisely it.
That attempt to make a wholly
different recipe to live by a
different set of rules that gets
defined explicitly as non
compliance.
It's basically saying we like
your spices but don't mess with
the core recipe.
And America, the source says,
has never had much patience for
non compliance.
Not much at all.
And that's where the Dremel
starts grinding this whole idea.
It really reframes pluralism,
doesn't it?
It's not this transformative
process where cultures truly
blend and change each.
Other no, it's just additive.
You can add things, but you
can't change the bass.
Exactly.
And the aha moment here for you
listening, is realizing that the
whole promise of American
pluralism, often sold as this
wide open, inclusive thing,
might actually be built with
these inherent limits baked
right in.
The welcome mat is out, but only
if you don't track mud on the
hamburger and apple pie carpet.
That's a good way to put it.
It challenges that idealized
view right from the start.
OK, And this leads to an even
more provocative idea, maybe
even unsettling, that what we
often call racism is actually
the sound of this Dremel
grinding.
Yeah, this.
Is a really key part of the
argument the source makes this
controversial claim.
What people call racism often
isn't just animus or prejudice.
Though that exists too, it adds,
it's important to say individual
hate is real.
Absolutely.
The source acknowledges that.
Explicit bias, hatred, that's
definitely part of the picture.
But it argues that a lot of what
gets labeled racism is something
else.
It is the grinding sound of the
Dremel.
So what is that grinding
exactly?
How does the Dremel work?
The source explains it like
this.
America is relentless in sanding
down edges, rounding off
corners, polishing difference
until it can be sold back to you
as flavor.
Wow.
Relentless sanding.
That's a powerful image.
It is.
It suggests it's not always
about conscious hate from
individuals, but more like the
intended function of a societal
machine.
It's the systematic process
where anything considered too
different just gets smoothed out
incrementally until it fits.
And the source uses a pretty
stark analogy for this, right?
That dark joke, Yeah.
It draws a direct parallel.
The phrase that best captures it
is the old dark joke.
The beatings will continue until
morale improves, and here the
source says it's not physical
beatings, but the sanding will
continue until you comply.
It really drives home this idea
of an unyielding, almost
inescapable pressure to conform.
It makes you think about how
that pressure feels.
And that's where the perspective
really matters.
The source points out that for
the communities being ground,
this whole process feels like
racism because it comes in the
form of punishment, exclusion,
hostility.
That's their lived reality of
the Dremel, this constant
pressure that feels like an
attack.
Right.
But, and this is crucial for
understanding the whole picture,
from the Hegemon's point of
view, it's simply the machinery
of assimilation doing its work.
So from the dominant cultures
perspective, it's not
necessarily malice, it's just
maintaining order, integrating
people.
Pretty much.
It's seen as ensuring cohesion,
bringing new elements into
what's perceived as the sort of
natural, correct way things
should be.
A necessary function, not
necessarily a punishment.
So this redefinition, it gives
us a systemic lens, doesn't it,
Instead of just looking at
individual prejudice?
Exactly.
It encourages you, the listener,
to think beyond just finding
individual bad guys and to
consider how institutions,
societal expectations, even
subtle cultural norms are the
Dremel.
These forces, not just overt
hate, might be the root of a lot
of what we call racism.
It suggests it's often the
system itself operating as
designed, producing conformity.
It shifts the focus from who is
grinding to what the grinding
machine is and how it works.
It's less about individual moral
failure and more about the kind
of automatic operation of this
cultural.
Machine.
A machine built to maintain a
certain kind of sameness.
It's this drive within the
system to keep its order, its
core identity.
That's why it can feel so
relentless.
And this machine, this Dremel,
it's not new, is it?
The historical record seems to
show this has been going on for
a long time.
Oh yeah, the source is very
clear.
We've been running this machine
for centuries.
It's baked into the American
project.
So let's look at that history.
Ellis Island is often the image
that comes to mind.
Maybe a bit romanticized.
Definitely romanticized.
It was a new start, sure, but
immigrants weren't just welcomed
with open arms, the source says.
They were often herded into
Americanization schools.
Herded not invited.
Right.
And this was direct, explicit
assimilation, compulsory.
The curriculum was all about
conformity.
They learned English, studied
civics, and were instructed to
drop their old ways.
Drop their old ways.
Not just learn new ones, but
actively discard the old.
Exactly.
It wasn't just about practical
skills.
It was about adopting a new
identity, shedding the past.
You know, things like hygiene
lessons that subtly frame
traditional practices as
backward, or civics lessons that
presented this one idealized
American identity, often
dismissing their own heritage.
And this pressure wasn't just in
schools, right?
It's out in society, too.
Absolutely.
The source gives examples like
the No Irish need apply signs.
Which weren't just prejudice.
They were pressure, economic
pressure, social pressure, a
tool of the Dremel, basically
pushing Irish immigrants to
Americanize.
Lose the accent, change the
habits just to get a job to be
accepted.
It wasn't just discrimination,
it was active shaping.
Active shaping.
Italians were told to shorten
their names.
Jews were pressured to lose the
Yiddish.
Poles were encouraged to leave
the old country at the dock.
These were strong societal
demands with real consequences
if you didn't comply.
So historically, the Dremel was
often pretty explicit, forceful,
not much room for genuine
cultural difference beyond the
superficial.
Very little.
It really set a pattern early
on.
Difference would be sanded down
until it fit the mole.
It was an active, often quite
harsh process.
And this didn't stop after the
early waves of immigration.
The Dremel kept working,
sometimes in ways that looked,
well, beneficial on the surface,
like the post World War 2 era.
Right.
The GI Bill, hugely important
legislation, transformed
millions of lives for the
better, no question.
But the source argues it also
acted as another Dremel tool,
more subtle this time.
Exactly.
Subtle but systemic pressure,
the GI Bill helped put millions
of veterans into tract homes and
suburban ranches.
Which sounds like the American
Dream.
It was, but the source makes a
key point.
This wasn't because it
celebrated difference, but
because it hammered everyone
into the same middle class mold.
Hammered them into a mold?
How so?
We'll think about that post war
boom, rising economy, mass media
growing, a big cultural push for
uniformity, the suburban house,
the nuclear family, buying
consumer goods.
That became the ideal.
The GI Bill gave people the
money to achieve that ideal.
So it created this strong pull
towards one specific way of
life, regardless of where your
family came.
From a very strong pull, the
goal was still uniformity.
Even in prosperity you could
still have some limited
pluralism maybe.
Like the hyphenated American, a
Polish, American, Italian.
Yeah, you could be Polish
American or Italian American or
Irish American.
Maybe keep some traditions at
home, but crucially, your kids
went to the same schools, play
baseball on the same teams, and
watch the same sitcoms.
Your heritage became more like a
private thing, not something
that changed how you
participated in public life.
Exactly.
It was ethnicity as an add on a
flavor.
The source repeats the metaphor.
Pluralism was tolerated only as
a seasoning on top of the
hamburger.
So even positive government
programs could serve the
assimilation machine.
Intentionally or not, yeah, it
shows how pervasive the drummel
is.
Not always through force, but
through incentives, social
norms, creating this widely
accepted path.
It's not always malicious.
Sometimes it's just the system
encouraging a certain kind of
cohesion, whatever the cultural
cost.
Now, to really understand
America's specific way of doing
this, the source brings in a
comparison with Germany, which
is really fascinating it.
Really is.
The author talks about living in
Germany under Angela Merkel and
experiencing their very
different model of assimilation,
much more explicit.
Explicit how?
Well, to get residency, the
author had to attend state-run
German classes and civics
lessons.
No beating around the Bush, the
requirements were clear.
Learn the language to be 1
level.
Study the laws and prove that
you understood the rules of the
House.
Prove you understood the rules
of the House.
It sounds very direct.
Very direct.
It wasn't about appreciating
culture, it was about measurable
integration into German public
life.
And Merkel was apparently quite
open about the goals.
Remarkably so, the source
mentioned.
She admitted that the point was
partly to get women from
conservative Muslim households
away from their husbands and
into rooms where the state could
teach them that in Germany they
had rights.
Wow, so a very clear, almost
paternalistic goal stated right
out loud.
Blunt, paternalistic, but
honest.
As the source puts it, you are
here.
You must learn to be German,
even if only in the public
square.
Even if only in public.
But even after doing all that,
learning the language, the laws,
there was still a line.
A very clear line, the author
says.
Germans would still never call
me German.
I had German residency, not
German blood.
I could follow every rule and
still only be a foreigner who
happened to live there.
So a fundamental difference
between belonging based on rules
versus belonging based on
bloodline essentially.
Exactly, and the source lands a
pretty heavy punchline on this.
That's what an ethnostate looks
like when it pretends to be
pluralist.
Woof.
OK, so using Germany as this
contrast really highlights
America's method, doesn't it?
Germany is overt upfront about
the rules.
America.
America's more subtle, more
indirect.
And that comparison makes you
wonder, you know, which way is
more honest or more effective,
even?
And what does it mean for people
trying to belong in either
place?
It does seem like there's more
than one way to run the
assimilation machine.
Germany's is like a hammer, very
obvious.
Well, America's is more
diffused, embedded in the
culture itself.
Harder to see maybe, but still
working.
So how does America do it
differently then, if not
compulsory classes?
The source says America works
differently.
We don't tell you outright that
the sanding will continue.
No explicit mandates usually.
So what's the tool?
Sitcoms and pop culture.
That's the chosen medium,
according to the source.
It points specifically to Norman
Lear's big shows in the 70s.
All in the Family, The
Jeffersons Welcome back, Carter.
Those iconic shows as
assimilation tools.
As soft propaganda, yeah.
The argument is they were
cleverly designed to show
mainstream of America that, you
know, immigrants and minorities
could be funny, lovable, little
quirky.
But ultimately harmless and
assimilated.
OK, I can kind of see that.
They presented a version of
diversity that was easy to
digest that didn't really
challenge the underlying
structure.
It's strange to think of those
shows which felt groundbreaking
in some ways as part of the
Dremel, but let's take the
examples.
Welcome back Cotter and the
Swathogs.
Right, diverse group seemed
rebellious, but the source says
they weren't revolutionaries.
They were just rough around the
edge as kids on their way to
becoming ordinary Americans.
Their differences were sort of
charming flaws on the way to
fitting in, getting sanded down
through the story.
Pretty much the rough edges were
meant to be polished off.
Or look at The Jeffersons moving
on up to that deluxe apartment
in the sky.
Yeah, that wasn't shown as
overturning the system.
It was framed as proof that
upward mobility worked.
Their success validated the
American Dream within the
existing system.
So it wasn't about changing the
rules, but winning by the
existing rules.
Exactly.
Even Archie Bunker's Bigotry and
All in the Family, it was often
played for laughs.
Which, the source argues, was a
way of teaching America to
tolerate difference as long as
it fit inside the sitcom set
right.
Difference became part of the
comedy, not a real threat to the
way things were.
So the Dremel works through
stories, through culture,
shaping how we see things, what
we expect, what we aim for,
without any government orders.
It's the incredible power of
entertainment as an assimilation
tool.
The grinding doesn't feel like
punishment.
It feels like humor, or success,
or just life unfolding.
It makes conforming seem normal,
even desirable.
The path of least resistance is
made to look like the most
appealing path.
That's the soft power of it.
These stories reinforce that
fitting in leads to acceptance.
Success, being too different, is
presented as well, either
temporary or a problem.
The Dremel becomes a set of
unspoken rules guiding us.
But the grinding is still
happening today, right?
Though maybe the germels target
has changed.
It seems so.
The source draws a sharp
contrast between those 70
sitcoms and today's pop culture.
Back then you saw modest
apartments, dads with union
jobs, a reachable middle class
life.
Now.
Now we see penthouses, we see
influencers and billionaires.
The whole aspirational picture
is different.
That's a huge shift, yeah.
How does that affect the Dremel,
the assimilation process?
Well, the source argues, pop
culture no longer sells modest
assimilation.
It sells fantasies.
Fanties.
Yeah, think about the old
American Dream.
Chicken in every pot and a car
in every driveway.
Maybe hard work, but seem
possible for many.
Attainable stability.
OK, and the new dream.
The new dream is private jets,
villas in Tulum and Kardashian
lifestyles.
It's not just a higher bar, it's
a totally different planet, a
fantasy endpoint with, as the
source says, no ladder, no
staircase to get there for most
people.
It's completely detached from
reality for almost everyone.
Exactly.
And that has a huge impact.
Immigrants who maybe used to see
a path, steady job, house,
better life for the kids.
Now look at these media
fantasies and assimilation feels
like a cruel joke.
The promised land looks like a
gated community they can't even
approach.
Right, but it's not just
immigrants feeling this way.
The source notes the natives to
feel like failures if they only
achieve what used to be
considered success.
Just having a decent job and a
house can feel like falling
short compared to the fantasy.
So the Dremel has raised the
stakes for everybody.
That's the argument.
The hegemon hasn't stopped
grinding, it's just raised the
bar so high that assimilation
feels like a cruel joke.
The target is now so elusive it
creates this widespread
disillusionment, this feeling of
inadequacy.
The assimilation process feels
less like opportunity and more
like punishment or just
impossible.
An impossible burden chasing a
mirage.
The friction is still there,
maybe even worse because the
goal posts have moved into outer
space.
It leads to this deep sense of
frustration, I think.
OK, now here's a twist.
Something that looks like less
Dremel action, but might
actually trigger a backlash.
The source talks about
settlement pluralism.
Yeah, this is really interesting
complex development that the
source says has creeped in.
What does that look like?
It describes communities where
people can live 80 years without
ever speaking fluent English. 80
years.
Wow.
Yeah, and it's possible because
there's an infrastructure.
Services get translated into
human Spanish, Mandarin.
Kids can even go through school
taking tests in their parents
language.
So you can maintain a whole
life, raise kids in your own
language and cultural context.
Pretty much creating these very
self-contained cultural world
within the larger society.
So instead of the melting pot.
The source says we've drifted
into a patchwork quilt of
settlements.
Which on the surface sounds
tolerant, right?
Like the opposite of the Dremel.
More accommodation, less
assimilation it.
Definitely only feels tolerant
and it often comes from a
genuine desire for cultural
preservation, community support,
but.
There's a but.
There's a warning, the source
argues, that while it feels
tolerant, it might also erode
the shared civic culture that
makes pluralism work.
Meaning without some common
ground, things fall apart.
That's the concern.
Without some baseline of
hamburgers and apple pie, some
shared foundation, the risk is
fragmentation.
The source uses a strong word.
If the baseline is gone, what's
left is Balkanization.
Balkanization.
That sounds serious.
What does that mean here?
Why is that the worry?
It refers to society breaking
down into smaller, isolated,
often mutually suspicious or
even hostile groups, like the
historical conflicts in the
Balkans.
The fear is that if different
groups become too separate, lose
that shared language, shared
values, basic understanding of
each other.
Society itself becomes unstable,
harder to govern, harder to
cooperate.
Exactly.
Mutual suspicion grows.
National cohesion phrase.
And here's the kicker, the
warning about the Dremel and
when the hegemon finally
notices.
Then the dominant culture feels
threatened by this
fragmentation.
Won't come with sitcom laugh
tracks, it'll come with Law and
Order.
The Grinding Dremel all over
again, but harsher this time.
Wow.
So the argument is,
paradoxically, that too much
separation, even if
well-intentioned, could trigger
a more aggressive Dremel
crackdown.
If the dominant culture feels
its core identity, its baseline,
is genuinely at risk, Yeah, the
response could be severe, moving
from soft cultural pressure to
overt enforcement.
It's a really complex dynamic, a
kind of precarious balance.
It suggests there's this maybe
unacknowledged tension.
If the dominant culture feels
things have gone too far, the
assimilation machine might react
forcefully.
The Dremel becomes a hammer.
And the source is very clear
about which group has felt this
Dremel most consistently, most
relentlessly.
Painfully clear.
No group knows this better than
African Americans. 400 years
later.
The grinding hasn't stopped
because full compliance has
never been achieved. 400 years.
It's the ultimate tragic example
of the Dremel's persistence.
It really is.
You can trace the Dremel through
literally every phase of African
American history.
Reconstruction after the Civil
War, trying to integrate
formerly enslaved people, but
often through restrictive Black
codes limiting their rights.
Then Jim Crow.
The most brutal, explicit Dremel
imaginable.
Segregation, violence, economic
control.
All designed to sand down any
hope of equality, forcing black
Americans into a subordinate
role.
Even the civil rights movement.
A powerful push against the
Dremel?
Absolutely, but met with
ferocious Dremel backlash,
resistance, violence, new forms
of control, and the source
points to mass incarceration
today as another form.
Another manifestation of the
Dremel disproportionately
impacting black communities
maintaining a kind of order
through.
Punishing.
Exactly.
The source sums it up.
It's been sometimes brutal,
sometimes paternalistic, always
sanding toward compliance.
And there's that heartbreaking
reason why the grinding never
stops, why full compliance is
never seen as achieved.
The unsandable factor.
Skin color color can't be sanded
down.
That simple profound fact.
This visible immutable
difference means full
assimilation to the white
hegemonic ideal is impossible.
It creates this permanent
friction.
The Dremel can never finish its
work.
So what is tolerated then within
this framework?
Flavor, The source says the
hegemon tolerates Black
churches, Black History Month,
Black pride as flavor.
Things that are seen as cultural
additions, not fundamental
challenges to the core.
Right, they enrich the disc
without changing the basic
recipe.
But, and this is the stark
warning, but the moment
blackness asserts itself as a
separate civic code.
As something autonomous, self
determining, not just fitting
into the hegemon's rules.
The beatings continue until
morale improves.
The Dremel cracks down hard.
It's the most potent example of
the Dremel's power, where race
prevents full assimilation,
leading to this endless cycle of
friction and enforcement.
So thinking about all this, how
does it change how we define
racism itself in America?
The source says it's.
Slippery.
It is slippery, and the source
asks, is it hatred?
Sometimes, yes, it fully
acknowledges that individual
hate exists and is racism.
But more often, it argues,
racism is the sound of forced
compliance, the endless sanding
down of people who refuse to
comply with the hegemons rules.
Which leads to that striking
conclusion.
What gets called racism is often
just hegemony enforcing its
laws.
Hegemony enforcing its laws, not
necessarily personal hate, but
the system maintaining its
order.
It reframes racism as often
being a systemic function of
power, almost bureaucratic in a
chilling way.
And that explains the different
perspectives, doesn't it?
From the outside, from the group
being round down, it feels like
hostility, aggression,
exclusion.
Absolutely.
But from the inside, from the
perspective of the dominant
system, those sane actions can
feel like order, like
maintaining necessary
boundaries, keeping things
cohesive, upholding the norms.
It's a powerful summary.
It really pushes you, the
listener, to look beyond
individual acts and see the
structure of the machine at
work.
To see that the grind might not
always stem from individual
malice, but from the system's
fundamental drive to maintain
itself, to keep the recipe
consistent.
The Dremel is just doing what it
was built for.
OK, so let's crystallize what
American pluralism is not,
according to this source says
very clearly it is not
multiculturalism.
Right, that's often how we think
of it, but the source rejects
that.
It's not about truly separate
cultures coexisting equally and
independently.
And it's also not a federation
of parallel systems, not
different groups operating
totally on their own term.
No, it comes back again to that
core metaphor.
It is hamburgers and apple pie
with whatever spice you sprinkle
on top.
That's the limit.
So you can be proud of your
background, have festivals,
food.
Yes, you can be proud of your
heritage.
You can have your parades and
your food and your festivals.
Those are the acceptable flavor
elements.
The things that don't challenge
the core.
You can celebrate your roots,
but they can't spread too far
into the public square.
That's the idea.
It really defines the boundaries
clearly.
It's integration into and
decoration of the dominant
culture, not separate spheres.
And that leads us to the bottom
line, the unspoken deal of
American.
Pluralism.
The contract, correct?
Yeah.
But when you step into the
public square, you are expected
to play by the hegemons rules.
That's the core requirement, the
price of admission to broader
society.
And that grinding sound?
The Dremel isn't an accident.
It's not a bug, it's a feature.
Exactly, The source states it
bluntly.
That is the deal, and the
grinding sound you hear when you
resist is not an accident.
It's the machine doing exactly
what it was built to do.
Wow, not an accident, but the
machine working as designed.
Powerful.
Maybe unsettling.
Final thought.
It suggests the friction isn't
random, it's engineered, and it
really makes you, the listener,
think about your own place in
this deal.
How do you navigate it?
What does it mean to live
inside, or maybe push against?
This isn't built like this.
What a journey through this
idea.
We've really unpacked this
pluralism in the Dremel
metaphor, how what looks like
diversity celebration can
actually be this relentless
grinding down of difference into
just.
And how that changes our view of
racism.
Not just hate, but often the
sound of the system enforcing
compliance, keeping that
hamburger and apple pie base
intact.
We saw it in history, compared
it to Germany, looked at how pop
culture plays a role, the
complexities of settlement
pluralism and the profound
ongoing grind experienced by
African Americans.
The public square has its rules,
its deal, and the Dremel is the
enforcer.
So it leaves us with a big
question, doesn't it?
If this Dremel is the machine
doing exactly what it was built
to do, what does that really
tell us about the fundamental
design, the true goals of
American Society?
And maybe more personally, for
all of us living here,
individuals, communities, what
does it mean to operate within
or maybe to resist a system that
seems engineered for these very
specific outcomes when it comes
to identity and culture?
Something to definitely reflect
on.
We hope this deep dive gives you
a new lens to think about your
own experiences and what you see
around you.
Thanks for joining us.